over the daily mail they reported it
let me read the headline china says it
will shoot pelosi's plane down if she
travels to taiwan under u.s fighter
escort speaker refuses to confirm trip
quote if u.s fighter jets escort paulus
is planted in taiwan it is an invasion
who xi jin a commentator for the chinese
state affiliated global times wrote on
twitter the pla has the right to force
forcibly dispel policy's plane and the
u.s fighter jets including firing
warning shots and making tactical
movements of obstruction if ineffective
then shoot them down who said wow plus
has not confirmed reports she will
travel to taiwan but the other news is
that the u.s has sent a carrier and a
strike group to the south china sea
so it does seem like things are
escalating a bit ladies and gentlemen it
is apocalypse night here las vegas
flooded there's like
war with china
there was an op-ed in the new york times
that said pelosi's trip to taiwan is too
dangerous
so i'm wondering if you got what do you
guys think about this i do kind of feel
like
china's bluster come on some some ccp
state media guy saying he's going to
shoot down pelosi yeah right yeah you
said at the top of the shows this is not
the ccp they said it was a it was a news
media organization no no this is the ccp
oh i thought you said it came out of the
news media it so so my point is
if you have a company in china it's the
ccp oh that i agree with yeah this
wasn't like
this is state propaganda state
propaganda so what i want to be careful
of it's not xi jinping the government or
the millet to pla coming out and saying
we will shoot you down it's their
propaganda arm saying we have a right to
shoot at you and if if he doesn't stop
you we will we can shoot you and they
also this says that they'll shoot at her
plane if she goes there but then later
in the thing it says we'll shoot at her
plane if she brings fighter escorts
that's a different situation if she just
goes in without escorts maybe there's
not saber rattling or or
the fourth turning
totally the fourth turning actually what
was it tony robbins just had on
who's the surviving one william strauss
or neil
theory one of them died yeah one of them
died but the other one was just talking
with tony robbins and it's getting
getting kind of real in this fourth turn
but apparently it ends
20 28. it's neil how's the one that's
still alive yeah if it ends 2028 we're
in it
so i don't know 2026 is i've heard 2026
is when things are gonna get absolutely
bonkers i just did a piece on this on my
youtube where um
200 i think it was glub i forget like
sir john globb
he studied empires the rise and the fall
of them and he said that 20 20 or 250
years is the maximum life span of a
country
united states will turn 20 uh 250 years
in 2026 so that kind of coincides with
that i even wrote down some other things
we meet all the criteria for an empire
and decline like you know massive
complexity that just seems unsustainable
supposedly climate deforestation
environmental degradation and then
changing relations between friendlies
and um and foes or heightening tensions
between them and there's there's other
things in there oh yeah yeah yeah i mean
uh cultural collapse
uh
wastefulness a lack of decorum i mean
like yeah decadence uh like basement of
the currency like like imagine like a
young woman pouring expensive honey into
a paper cup with really expensive
liquors
right that shows based around decadence
what an animal and you know there's
there's one other funny thing when going
back through like rome all the way
through many other empires apparently in
the late stages of it
um they all seem to highlight uh chefs
they make celebrities out of their chefs
oh i read that yeah yeah it's it's just
some weird anomaly no i i yeah man i
wonder if there's like an emergent
phenomenon around
food and chefs and like so much well
you're you're so comfortable you're
entertained by
taking food to the most extreme levels
it's
pure gluttony and then also turning like
animals into babies
like how many times have you seen little
dogs in like cradles like all dressed up
and everything that's got to be a sign
of an empire in decline yeah the chef
celebrities and baby pets i noticed like
when i watched these survival videos of
people like carving building their own
house with their axe and stuff and then
it'll cut to them like frying really
crappy spam or something in a pan and
then like cooking and eating it i'm like
this is not appetizing why is this part
of the video
of them like cutting up their meat i
guess it's like people want to know what
it's like to live out in the woods and
hunt and cook your own stuff but
that's that's like the opposite of
decline like watching a video of some
super ripped dude killing a deer and
then
eating it but it'll this will be like he
opens a can of tuna and then has some
carrots like frozen carrots and i'll be
cooking it in a pan okay so that's what
well this is like chef and decline
that's post-apocalyptic yeah you know
this is like celebrity chef the real
yeah that's 2028
is making the cakes that you can't
where they're distinguish i could cut
this right now and it could be a cake it
could be just isn't that a netflix show
it is yeah are you serious have you seen
the video where the guy he's watching
the the videos of people like cutting a
shampoo bottle on cake and he looks
shocked and then he like grabs his phone
and squeeze it it's cake
freaks out and then he like grabs his tv
remote squeeze it it's cake and he
starts panicking and then he looks down
at his butt and he grabs his butt in its
cake and he's like
anything yeah everything is cute
everything is why
what's up with this i i think i think
tim's on to something there that um
i forget it wasn't john perkins it was
somebody else that was saying like
there's this feeling in whether it's a
nation or an empire that like times were
great we were great but no one's feeling
it anymore like there's there's another
one mercenaries when you have to start
fighting you know hiring mercenaries for
fighting your wars for you
like the the god and country isn't
working anymore
then and same thing with the bread and
circuses i think it's part of the whole
chef thing as part of the bread and
circuses thing did you see that they're
having serious problems recruiting
people for the military they've lowered
the education standard they've lowered
the fitness standard we're going to have
worse fought by mercenaries in no time
yeah i i wouldn't doubt that actually
what's interesting i was in the military
from 2000 to 2006
and everyone that uh like when i got
basically to my unit everyone was saying
like yeah you know you kind of went
through the you know the the piece of
cake boot camp where they can't touch
you they can't hit you they can't push
you and like you didn't need to do you
know even half as much of the running as
we needed to so even back then about 20
years ago
apparently it was like a
shell of what it used to be boot camp
interesting we had blackwater fighting a
huge part or at least if not fighting
the war in the middle east they were
like functioning as administration for
alarm i mean that's mercenary
well look look at ukraine
american citizens are on the ground in
ukraine but the u.s is like we didn't
send them there right they're not
officially ours and it's like an
international cohort of individuals
fighting this war but so you said
countries got 250 years but what about
like france which had 900 000 years
well it's empires it's not countries
it's empires so like other empires are
still around you know other like great
britain's
still around you know but has the u.s
been an empire for 250 years it hasn't
well not not an empire and that's a good
point because uh 17 i don't i don't know
when they start the clock either right
when you are officially an empire
because i know 1776
i guess you wouldn't have called the
united states an empire you know it
wasn't it wasn't until i think like the
1900s that the u.s went totally
empirical
i mean yeah federal 46 even who is that
who is that guy that everybody hates
woodrow wilson oh man yeah everybody
hates that guy right it really it was
like after world war ii they realized if
we don't become a world order
um
empire whatever that we're gonna have
world war three so they were like
liberal economic order which you could
call an empire um we got military bases
all over the earth signing the liberal
international economy yes the lie the
lie was established in 1946 it's it's
also this is a different world than
all the other empires when we were you
know like mapping out this 250 year life
span as well where i mean when you're
talking about nations and empires you're
also talking about like major economic
blocks like transnational economic
blocks i also want to point out
isn't it that empires last 250 years on
average
is it well i mean the soviet union
lasted 69 years
yeah and that was massive i mean they
were spreading all over the planet
remnants still exist in some fashion
today the us
i mean
i wonder if the 250 years thing is is
based upon
the extent of communications without
electronics
right so all of these big empires
communicated through letter delivery
carrier horseback
now we have rapid communication that
causes things to evolve much more
quickly
especially now with the internet and
social media it's just ramping up faster
than
so i mean you think about uh franz
ferdinand right he gets shot how long
did it take for everyone to find out
probably not that long relative to now
but it was lightning speed relative to
previous conflicts telegraph radio word
went out to their countries really
quickly but how long did it take for
regular people to find out you know if
we had something like that happen today
it'd be on social media
the moment it happened everyone would
see it so it's even faster
that that anger that animosity
the conflict can spread instantly across
across every person so you think about
the conflicts we've had in this country
sentiment for civil war right in the
united states how long did it take for
an idea to go from one person to
everyone in a city to make it from new
york to you know illinois or to you know
down to florida like those ideas to
change and then create rifts probably
took a really really long time well you
look at like the first persian empire
and one of the biggest reasons they
collapsed internally was because of all
of these internal rifts they were having
rebellions they were taking slaves and
bringing them into their military and
making them mercenaries as we were
talking about and now because of
technology like you're saying we're
having this ramping up of that kind of
stuff and rebellions like black lives
matter internally
causing rebellion within the us all of
these and then we also have information
that shows us that you have russia china
potentially pumping money into these
internal rebellions that we're facing in
the west and you're right we're going to
have basically a repeat
of what caused a lot of these past
empires to collapse on crack because of
the technological
fentanyl yeah it's the waiting i can't
stand
yeah yeah just bring it home
ian's talking about a guy in the woods
like cracking open an old can of tuna
and putting carrots in it and i'm like
sounds pretty good
i can't wait i wonder if this is
actually an american empire or if it's
just the british empire and masked with
the american military because
that's part of it there's actually an
empire that's part of it there's also
like a math equation this one guy it was
an old ted talks but he was saying like
even in a back uh bacterial petri dish
uh dish mismatches between resources and
consumption cause
things like five generations in before
the or before the decline
it's the population is doubling every
single uh generation and then five
generations before the decline
the food declines by 15 16. the next
generation by three-fourths
and it's empty in the next generation uh
or in the next generation is about half
and then the following generation is the
mathematical conclusion of it i don't
know if that if that petri dish is a
one-on-one parallel to what we're
dealing with but well so you you've
heard that uh wealth lasts three
generations they say right the first
generation
is you know comes up figures it out
works hard and then has that within them
this individual they have kids those
kids learn a lesson from the the first
generation they inherit the wealth and
they know a little bit enough to kind of
just sort of maintain it
now you have another generation and
they're learning a lesson about a lesson
it's it's a it's a copy of a copy and so
by the third generation they're they
have no idea how the empire was built
they have no idea how to start a company
they don't have the same life lessons
so i have to think about this too
you know i hear stories about
people who they're like i was a college
dropout and i was poor and i worked hard
and then now they have kids and those
kids are children of the wealthiest
people on the planet they're not going
to learn the same lesson like steve jobs
was homeless he was like sleeping on
couches and floors
and then he was he he had that fire
within him and ruthlessness let's be
real
his kids you know i don't know i'm
assuming he has kids but like the
children of these people don't have that
they grew up in luxury
totally i know it's like such a tired
analogy the good men bad times thing but
they've got another arab parable that's
like just like what you're talking about
where it's like i'll ride a camel my son
will ride will ride in a toyota his son
will ride in a ferrari and then his son
will ride a camel and there's a reason
that these parables exist though the
good men hard times whatever it's
because it's just what happens every
damn time and humanity keeps trying to
tell us we've lived this story a billion
times but all right guys good luck do it
again have fun that's why i'm saying
like
when i have kids
like
i'm gonna kick them out at three years
old and be like
here's a bandana a trowel a pack of
seeds and a pointy stick good luck maybe
a match if you don't know but but in all
seriousness what we do is we take the
newborn we put him in the woods for a
day and if he survives he's strong
enough to join the truck that's true i
think that's some george carlin no no
that was the spartans i think they did
that right if the baby didn't survive
like out in the wilderness it wasn't
strong enough well and then you know
nothing crazy like that but i certainly
think you gotta teach
i mean like hard labor like good manual
labor chores lifting stuff shoveling
mowing the lawn you gotta teach kids you
know that those kind of lessons thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you